number one go go
stay focused the art in here is worth
millions one of the things that really
made this a pleasure to work on was that
the art collection was really curated
you got seven minutes only are very
tangible and as an actor it helped root
the story
sorry you're on your own
thank you
come in number three
The Collection that is built here mixes
sculpture paintings but also New Media
[Music]
it as a visual artist so I found someone
that was able to recognize the value of
the artworks that were selected like the
neon by David horvitz
and the daughter of Mauritius
for the film
like the oranges of Albert Bano
the drawing of Francesco Clemente
[Music]
the challenges were very much about
making the artists understand the
context in which they were giving the
work because
we have to have complete control of the
artwork within the film narrative
the idea of how each single work speaks
to The Narrative of the film speaks to
Nemo to do certain things in the space
he's going to build a shelter for
example I immediately thought about Yana
petrovska's photograph series of
shelters
this character because he's trapped he
has to invent his escape and in this
case art making art even though he's not
an artist it has something to do with
his survival he expresses that by
starting to draw on the walls or
interact with some of the art pieces
one of the main topics of the collection
is the idea of power and control this
idea that Nemo is trapped inside the
space
it's very much resonating with some of
the works I feel you brother I gotta set
you free
we had this beautiful sculpture the
steel rings by Ryan tabith physically
extending from the inside of the house
to the outside which is exactly what
Nemo is not able to do
yeah but as pigeons
right right
I also thought about aegon Chile is a
very recognizable Master but also that
the physicality of the artworks that we
selected these portraits are very much
the physicality of Nemo the way he
transforms
movies for me are most powerful not not
just because of an exotic idea but when
you can give the audience new way of
saying and kind of inspire a different
kind of way to look at things
cats die
music fades
but Art Is For Keeps